البحريه الاسرائيليه ترفع درجه الجاهزيه
في البحر الاحمر تحسبا لاعتداءات ايرانيه
الطاقه الذريه تقول انها تجري مناقشات مع
ايران بعد تقرير عن اقتراب طهران من
السلاح النووي
والاتحاد الافريقي يعلن اعتزمه تنظيم
مؤتمر بشان المصالحه الوطنيه في ليبيا
[موسيقى]
حياكم الله مشاهدينا الكرام اهلا بكم معنا
الى هذه النشره المفصله تاتيكم من العربيه
افدت وسائل اعلامنا اسرائيليه برفع قوه
البحريه لدرجه التاهب في البحر الاحمر
خوفا من هجوم ايراني وقال تقارير
اسرائيليه انه بعد استهداف سفن تابعه
لاسرائيل قبل ايام دفعت البحريه لتوقع او
لسفن دفع بحريه عفوا توقع هجمات ايرانيه
جديده في البحر الاحمر خاصه ان ايران كتفت
من وجودها في البحر الاحمر منذ العام
الماضي بوضع عناصر عسكريه على متن سفن
مدنيه
كان رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي بنيامين
دنياهو قال ان اسرائيل لن تسمح لايران
بامتلاك اسلحه نوويه
ايران تحاول ايذاء اسرائيل ومواطنيها
اينما كانوا في العالم بلا هوادم هجمات
ايران لن تضبط عزيمتنا لن نسمح لايران
بامتلاك اسلحه نوويه ولا نسمح لها
بالتمركز على طول حدودنا الشماليه نفعل كل
شيء وسنبدو القصار جهدنا لحمايه مواطنينا
ونرد بشده على الهجمات ضدنا
وفي الاثناء قالت الوكاله دوليه للطاقه
ذريه انها تناقش نتائج انشطه التحقق
الاخيره مع ايران بعد ان افاد تقارير
اعلاميه بان الوكاله اكتشفت يورانيوم مخصب
بدرجه نقاء تبلغ 84% وهو ما يقترب من درجه
صنع الاسلحه اضافه الوكاله انها ستبلغ
مجلس محافظي الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه
الذريه حسب الاقتضاء
افاد المرصد السوري بمقتل سبعه عسكريين
بينهم ثلاثه ضباط في القصف الاسرائيلي على
دمشق من جهته كشف نائب رئيس المركز الروسي
للمصالحه في سوريا اوليج غورينوف ان سلاح
الجو الاسرائيلي نفذ الغار الجويه على
دمشق باستخدام اربع مقاتلات اف 16 تابعه
لسلاح الجو الاسرائيلي وقد وجه الضربه
صاروخيه على دمشق من سماء الجولان واسفرت
الغاره عن تدمير مباني معهد الفنون
التطبيقيه والمركز الثقافي في منطقه كفر
سوسه في دمشق
الاستخبارات الاوكرانيه ان القوه النوويه
الاستراتيجيه الروسيه اجرت مناورات واسعه
تزامنا مع زياره الرئيس الامريكي لاوروبا
وقد اعتبرت اوكرانيا ان المناورات الروسيه
هدفها اضعاف الدعم الدولي لاوكرانيا ومنع
زياره بايدن المقرره الاثنين لاوروبا
اوضحت الاستخبارات الاوكرانيه ان القوات
النوويه الروسيه استعدت برا وبحرا وجوا
واجرت فحصا لنظام التحكم القتالي اضافه
لصواريخ كروس
نقلت صحيفه بليتكو عن مسؤولين امريكيين
قولهم ان اداره الرئيس جو بايدن طلبت من
اوكرانيا عزيزه مكاسبها والاستعداد لشن
هجوم مضاد على روسيا واوضح المسؤولون ان
اداره بايدن تتخوف من عدم قدرتها على
ارسال مساعده الى اوكرانيا بسبب
الجمهوريين واشار المسؤولون الامريكيون ان
مساعدي بايدن باحثوا زياره زيارته
لاوكرانيا ثم تم استبعاد الفكره
اتهمت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه اوكرانيا
بانها تخطط لهجوم النوويه على اراضيها
لتحميل موسكو مسؤوليته او مسؤوليات هذا
الهجوم قبل اجتماع للامم المتحده وقالت
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان مواد مشعه تم
نقلها الى اوكرانيا من دوله اوروبيه وان
كيف تستعد لعمل استفزازيا واسع النطاق
واضافت الدفاع الروسيه ان الهدف من الخطه
هو اتهام الجيش الروسي بشن هجمات عشوائيه
مزعومه على منشات مشعه خطره في اوكرانيا
مما يؤدي الى تسرب مواد مشعه وحدوث تلوث
في المنطقه
ميدانيا افاد اعلام روسي باجلاء السكان من
ضواحي باخماط في دونات بسبب قصف اوكراني
وقد اعلن عمده مدينه دوناتس كالمؤيد
لروسيا عن ايقافي عمل المواصلات العامه في
المدينه تحسبا لتطورات القصف الاوكراني
بعد استهداف مناطق متفرقه من المدينه
باربعين صاروخا او صاروخ ذمباير تشكيكا او
تشيكيا عفوا وخمس قاذفات ام سبعه سبعه كما
شمل القصف مدافع
واسفر عن اصابه شخصين واضرار ماديه
تحاول القوات الاوكرانيه تجهيز نفسها
لتسابق الزمن من خلال تدريب جنودها
والحصول على المزيد من الاسلحه الغربيه
المتقدمه استعدادا لمواجهه هجوم الروسيه
المحتمل خلال الربيع المقبل وذلك بعد
السنه من القتال الذي لم يحسم الصراع
لصالح اي من الطرفين
عجله الحرب في اوكرانيا لا تتوقف عن
الدوران فصول اربعه عاشتها المعركه في
انتظار فصل خامس
كيف تستعد لصد هجوم روسي محتمل خلال
الربيع
هجوم يسبقه تكتيك روسي جديد يتمثل في
اطلاق مناطيد تحمل عاكسات رادار فوق
اوكرانيا للحصول على معلومات بشان انظمه
الدفاع الجوي الاوكراني لاجبار كييف على
استنزاف مخزوناتها القيمه من الذخيره
والصواريخ ارض جو حسب الدفاع البريطانيه
لمواجهه ذلك الاوكرانيون فتحوا خطه تعبئه
طوعيه جديده وفق صحيفه الطعام الصحيفه
ذاتها نقلت عن مستشار زيلينسكي قوله ان
معركه السيطره على باخموت مهمه وان
اوكرانيا لن تتخلى عنها ابدا اذ تعتبرها
مفتاح الصراع ولا مجال لخسارتها فالسيطره
على باخموت ستشكل نقطه انطلاق بالنسبه
لروسيا للزحف نحو مدينتين اكبر هما اكرم
تورسك اللتين تقعان ابعد باتجاه الغرب في
دونياتك ما سيعيد الزخم قبل الذكرى الاولى
لانطلاق الحرب ولتحقيق هذا الهدف تطالب
اوكرانيا حلفائها الغربيين بالمزيد من
الطائرات المقاتله والدبابات الحربيه
المتقدمه في وقت تؤكد انها تحتاج ايضا
صواريخ بعيده المدى لصد الهجوم الروسي
واستعاده السيطره على المناطق التي خسرتها
فالجيش الاوكراني يستهلك القذائف بوتيره
اسرع مما يمكن للغرب ان يصنع حسب رويترز
ما يمثل عقبه اخرى امام قوتكياف خلال
المرحله المقبله بلال البجدين العربيه
اكد وزير الخارجيه الامريكي
ان الصين تخطط لارسال اسلحه الى روسيا
وكشف بلانكنان الصين تقدم دعما ماديا
لروسيا وتدرس تحويل هذا الدعم الى عسكري
ايضا الصين بتحمل عواقب وخيمه اذا اقدمت
على تصليح موسكو اثناء حربها في اوكرانيا
لقد كنا قلقين منذ اليوم الاول بشان هذا
الاحتمال وحتى الان راينا شركات صينيه
وبالطبع في الصين لا يوجد فرق بين الشركات
الخاصه والتابعه للدوله رايناهم يقدمون
دعما دون اسلحه قتاليه لروسيا لاستخدامه
في اوكرانيا ان القلق الذي يساوينا الان
يستند الى معلومات لدينا تفيد بانهم
يفكرون في تقديم دعم قاتل وقد اوضحنا لهم
ان ذلك من شانه ان يسبب مشكله خطيره في
علاقاتنا
على طلب في الاخر قال وانجي كبير
دبلوماسيين الصينيين انه على امريكا تعزيز
التسويه السياسيه في اوكرانيا بدلا من
تاجيج الصراع اضافا ان الولايات المتحده
بصفتها قوه عظمى يجب ان تتوقف عن صب الزيت
على النار بما يخدم مصالحها الخاصه مشيرا
الى ان الصين التزمت بموقف بناء بشان
الازمه ودعمت التفاوض على عكس ما تفعله
امريكا
خلال فتره الحرب طفره الضو تفرض حراسه
مشدده على زعماء البلدان المتحاربه الامر
الذي لا يختلف بالنسبه للرئيسين الروسي
والاوكراني بين قطار بوتين المدرع ومخبز
السري تباينت وسائل الحمايه في وقت تستمر
المعارك الضاريه
قطار بوتين المدرع وملجا زيلينسكي تحت
الارض بين كياف وموسكو اختلفت وسائل
الحمايه المخصصه لزعيم البلدين زمن الحرب
بوتان يستعمل القطار خلال تنقلاته في جميع
انحاء روسيا والوصول الى قصوره الخاصه
القطار مطلي باللونين الاحمر والرمادي ما
يجعله كاي قطار ركاب عادي هو عباره عن
عربه رئاسيه بها غرفه نوم بالاضافه الى
مقصوره مجهزه بمعدات الاتصالات المتطوره
كلف بناؤه اكثر من 13 مليون دولار يقال
الرئيس الروسيه مقتنع بان السفر فيه اكثر
امانا من ركوب الطائرات التي يسهل تتبعها
الحكايه مختلفه في كييف زيليسكي يحتمي تحت
الارض في مخبا سري يطلق عليه اسم بانكوفا
وهو كتله خرسانيه من المكاتب المحاطه
بحلقه من الفولاذ تصطف حوله نقاط التفتيش
مع حراس مسلحين لا يسمحون بدخول اي شخص
سوى من لديهم تصريح بذلك ويطلب الجنود من
الموجودين كلمات مرور سريه تتغير يوميا
وغالبا ما تكون عبارات يصعب على الروس
نطقها استخدمه زيلينسكي واعضاء حكومته
خلال سيطره الجيش الروسي على بلدات مجاوره
بعد ذلك تغيرت الخطه وخرج زيلينسكي ومن
معه
بلال الوجداني العربيه
في ان كوريا الشماليه اطلقت صاروخا
باليستيه او صواريخ باليسيه قصيره المدى
في ثاني عمليه اطلاق خلال يومين والتي
تاتي الولايات المتحده وكوريا الجنوبيه
تدريبات جويه مشتركه كم
شقيقه الزعيم الكوري الشمالي قالت
تدرس بعنايه تاثير زياده الوجود
الاستراتيجي الامريكي في المنطقه مشيره
الى ان استخدام المحيط الهادي كميدان
رمايه يعتمد على سلوك الولايات المتحده
ما ان اطلق هذا الصاروخ البالستي العابر
للقارات حتى ادانته كل من كوريا الجنوبيه
والولايات المتحده واليابان التي قالت انه
سقط في منطقتها الاقتصاديه الخالصه ما
يعني انه قادر على ضرب اي مكان في البر
الرئيسي لامريكا
هو الاول منذ سبعه اسابيع حلقى 66 دقيقه
بمسافه تصل الى 14 الف كيلو متر اطلقته
كوريا الشماليه في اطار تدريب مفاجئ على
حد تعبيرها وحينما عبرت الدول الثلاثه عن
موقفها مع تمديد مجموعه السبع اكدت
بيونغيانغ خبر الصاروخ الاخير
واعتبرت ان نجاح اختبارها دليل على قدرتها
على شن هجوم نووي مضاد وفتاك فالزعيم كيم
جونغ اون وافق على التدريب شخصيا وخططيا
بلا اشعار مسبق
وردا عليه ياتي سرب الطائرات هذا حيث اعلن
الجيش الكوري الجنوبي تنظيم مناورات جويه
مشتركه مع الولايات المتحده
شاركت فيها طائرات الشبح وقاذفه امريكيه
بعيده المدى واحده على الاقل وقال وزير
الدفاع الكوري الجنوبي ان المناورات سمحت
باظهار النشر الفوري لوسائل الردع
الامريكيه الموسعه في شبه الجزيره الكوريه
ما يدل على القوه الكاسحه للحلفاء
وما تزال مساله امتلاك كوريا الشماليه
لصاروخ باليسي عابر للقارات يعمل برؤوس
نوويه موضع نقاش خارجي اذ يقول بعض
الخبراء انبيون جانج لم تتقن تقنيه لحمايه
الرؤوس الحربيه من الظروف القاسيه
لمعاوده دخول الغلاف الجوي
نشرتنا مستمره مشاهدينا وفيها بعد قليل
اسطنبول المهدده بالزلازل تسابق الزمن
لتامين مبانيها
اهلا بكم من جديد كشف رئيس المفوضيه
الاتحاد الافريقي موسيقي محمد ان المنظمه
ستنظم مؤتمرا بشان المصالحه الوطنيه في
ليبيا في احدث محاوله لاعاده الاستقرار
الى ليبيا وقال فقي في مؤتمر صحفي اختتمت
به او اختتمت به قمه الاتحاد الافريقي ان
لقاءات تمت مع مختلف الاطراف والمنظمه
بصدد العمل معهم لتحديد موعد او موعد
ومكان عقد المؤتمر الوطني الذي سيلتان
برعايه لجنه رفيعه المستوى من الاتحاد
الافريقي يتراسها الرئيس الكونغولي
واضاف فقه محمدا اجتماعات اجتماعا تحضيريا
عقد قبل بضعه اسابيع في طرابلس موضحا انه
تم طلب مغادره المرتزقه
وينبغي بالضروره ان يتحاور الليبيون وهو
شرط مسبق للمضي نحو انتخابات في بلد هادئ
وف محمد
الخارجيه الامريكيه
انه التقى مع ممثلينا عن منظمه الدفاع
المدني السوريه الخوذه البيضاء خلال
زيارته الحاليه الى تركيا اضافه عبر حسابه
على تويتر تفتخر بدعم الخوذ البيضاء
والمنظمات الاخرى التي تقدم المساعده في
مواجهه تداعيات الزلزال المدمر الذي ضرب
سوريا وتركيا مؤخرا
[موسيقى]
اعلن وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه خلال زيارته
لتركيا عن مساعده جديده بقيمه 100 مليون
دولار للمتضررين من الزلزال المدمر الذي
راح ضحيته عشرات الالاف من الاشخاص في
تركيا وسوريا بامكان اليوم ان اعلن باننا
وفرنا مئه مليون دولار اخرى لمساعده
الاشخاص الذين في امس الحاجه اليها لقد
جلبنا هذا المبلغ من صندوق الطوارئ
للاجئين والهجره وكذلك من صندوق المساعده
الانسانيه التابع لوزاره الخارجيه
والوكاله الامريكيه للتنميه الدوليه
نحن مصممون على بذل كل ما في وسعنا
لمساعده الشعب التركي والشعب السوري ايضا
وسنبذل كل جهدنا لتحقيق ذلك نحن متاثرون
جدا بما اصابهم كل ما اريد ان يعرفه شعب
تركيا هو ان الولايات المتحده تقف الى
جانبهم وسنظل معهم حتى يتجاوزون ازمتهم
مهما استغرق الامر من وقت
على الحدود تركيا السوريه حركه بعد وقوع
الزلزال من خلال دخول شاحنات المساعدات
ونقل الضحايا فضلا عن عوده الكثير من
اللاجئين الى سوريا بشكل طوعي بعد النكبات
التي المت بهم المناطق المتضرره في سوريا
لا تزال تنزف من اثار الزلزال والدعوه
باتت ملحه من اجل التحرك لانقاذ الوضع
منظمه اطباء بلا حدود انضمت الى المؤسسات
الداعيه الى زياده المساعدات الانسانيه
الى شمال غرب سوريا وذلك بشكل عاجل
اكثر من اربعه ملايين سوري في مناطق
الزلزال شمال البلاد في خطر جديد
الخطر سببه نقص المساعدات والمواد اللازمه
لما بعد الكارثه
هذه المساعدات تتمثل بتامين الماوى
والمياه النظيفه والامدادات الطبيه
للعمليات الجراحيه
منظمه اطباء بلا حدود اطلقت نداء جديدا
لاغاثه المنطقه
المنظمه افرغت مخزونها في الايام الثلاثه
الاولى من الكارثه
تقول المنظمه الى المساعدات الخارجيه اقل
من معدلها الاسبوعي عام 2022
مؤخرا منظمه الغذاء العالمي اتهمت سلطات
المنطقه بعرقله ادخال المساعدات
في تركيا يعيش سكان الاحياء العتيقه
بمدينه اسطنبول حاله خوف من حدوث زلزال
محتمل وفق ما اعلنه خبراء فيما اطلقت
سلطات البلديه انذارا تحذيريا عاجلا
لاصحاب ما يزيد عن 100 الف بنايه هشه من
اجل فحصها وتاكد من سلامتها
مع كل هزه ارتداديه جديده يشعر بها
الاتراك تهتز معها قلوب سكان هذه الاحياء
والاف من قاطني بنايات وصف عمده اسطنبول
هياكلها بالخطيره
انها مساله حياه او موت هكذا حذرت سلطات
اسطنبول السكان هنا داعيه اصحاب البنايات
الهشه والقديمه الى الاسراع في فحسها وهنا
علي تركي من اصول عربيه يعيش بهذه البنايه
المتصدعه في حي الفاتح منذ سنوات في
تشققات
الفاتح وعندي هون تشفقات فوق وانا ما بقول
لك ما في خوف في خوف بس شلون الوضع عم بطل
لبره مثلا يوم صار شيء عم بطلها
كل ما يشغل باله هذه الايام هو كيفيه
انقاذ عائلته في حال تحركت الارض
والله يسترنا اذا كان وضع مثلا بدي يهدوا
يهدوا
مو انا بقرف على اولادك لكن شلون كل واحد
خايف على اولنا غير الله سبحانه وتعالى
وهالاولاد
احصت بلديه اسطنبول ما يزيد عن 100 الف
بنايه بحاجه عاجله الى فحص ضوئي واوسط
باتخاذ قرارات صارمه لانقاذ ملايين
الارواح في ظل توقعات خبراء بحدوث زلزال
هائل خلال السنوات القادمه
نحن نتوقع ان يحدث زلزال اخر قد لا يكون
مركزه في اسطنبول لكنها ستتضرر كثيرا
خصوصا اننا لم نحضر جيدا لذلك فكثير من
البنايات غير مطابقه للزلازل ويجب اعاده
النظر سريعا في معايير البناء
[تصفيق]
ردا على الاعتقالات وهدم المنازل اعلن
الفلسطينيون الاضراب العام والعصيان
المدني في مخيم شعفاط وبلده العيساويه
واحياء اخرى في القدس الشرقيه لكن رغم
توتر الاوضاع يصروا وزير الامن القومي
المتطرف
على استمرار الاستفزازات الاسرائيليه في
المنطقه بحجه النشاط الامني
كذا بدت مظاهر العصيان المدني هنا في حي
العيساويه واحياء اخرى في القدس الشرقي
اضراب تجاري واغلاق شوارع ومواجهات بين كر
وفر بين الشبان والقوات الاسرائيليه التي
انتشرت بكثافه حاول بين المي العادمه
بالرصاص والغاز والمطاط كل الطرق يلغوا
هذا العصيان ولكن استمر لهذه الشعر خطوه
الاحتجاج التي امتدت الى معظم احياء القدس
الشرقيه جاءت احتجاجا على ما يصفه الناس
هنا بحمله انتقام وتنكيل وتضييق يقودها
وزير الامن القومي الاسرائيلي المتشدد بنج
فير متمثله بهدم المنازل وتحرير مخالفات
سير وملاحقات ضريبيه الى جانب الاعتقالات
والمداهمات انه احدث جهود محطات بامل ان
شاء الله تكون رساله برضو للقياده
وفلسطينيه والمجتمع الدولي انه ينظر بعين
الاعتبار للاهداف اللي بتصير زي ما تبارك
على الشعب
رغم التوتر في القدس الشرقيه اعلن بنجفير
انه لن يتراجع عن الاجراءات العقابيه التي
اعقبت العمليات الفرديه في القدس ما ينذر
بما هو اخطر حيث حذر المفتش العام للشرطه
يعكفاي ان هذه الاجراءات ستؤدي الى غليان
وتفجير للاوضاع
من ان يكون العصيان المدني هذا بمثابه
شعله لمواجهه قد تجر الضفه الغربيه الى
تصعيد اكبر واشعال الاوضاع الامنيه في ظل
اصرار الحكومه الاسرائيليه على استمرار
النشاط الامني في القدس الشرقيه لان كلاسي
من القدس الشرقيه المحتله العربيه
نشره الى العناوين
البحريه الاسرائيليه ترفع درجه الجاهزيه
في البحر الاحمر تحسبا لاعتداءات ايرانيه
الطاقه الذريه تقول انها تجري مناقشات مع
ايران بعد تقرير عن اقتراب طهران من
السلاح النووي
الاتحاد الافريقي يعلن اعتزامه تنظيم
مؤتمر بشان المصالحه الوطنيه في ليبيا
دائما مشاهدينا العربيه دوت لمزيد من
المتابعه القاكم بعد دقائق
[موسيقى]